[Musique]
après trois ans de travaux le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'est enfin
ouvert au regard des curieux plutôt
massive et froides à l'extérieur l'
architecture intérieure choisi par
stanislas fille soeur a séduit de
manière unanime un équipement ou même
les détails ont trouvé leur place au
dessus des 2 salles qui peuvent
accueillir respectivement 1200 et 350
places des appartements ont été
construits pour les artistes des loges
également étudié en fonction des
passages que ce soit des orchestres des
troupes ou des chanteurs bref une
utilisation facilement aménageable pour
toutes les personnes qui vont faire
vivre ce théâtre comme pour le public
qui dispose aussi de lieu d'exposition
reste la programmation et le prix des
places
elle ne devrait pas décevoir non plus il
y aura à 40 spectacles 40 spectacles et
il y aura
du théâtre bien entendu il y aura de la
danse avec des compagnies
internationales et nationales
il y aura
du théâtre musical et lyrique il y aura
aussi un secteur voix ouvert à tous ce
programme présentera également un
avantage dès le mois d'octobre prochain
d'être accessible financièrement à un
large public grâce à des tarifs modérés
une saison qui devrait logiquement
commencé le 2 octobre avec la chanteuse
de jazz dee dee bridgewater
les subventions du salon pour le budget
de fonctionnement du théâtre ayant été
cette semaine
votez en comité syndical
[Musique]